was zum teufel ist das ich habe da nie
gesehen dass er ein bis sie muratow
gespielt hat und da dachte ich mir den
muss ich auch mal was bist du denn auch
dass das bin ich okay ich bin dieser typ
und ich will oder dieses meter oder was
zum teufel ist das was bin ich ich kann
ihr verschiedene dinge auswählen wie
brüste schuhe ring oder hose oder
irgendwie so kam ich auch ins bett legen
die zeit geht voran allerdings sollte
ich jetzt mal an den pc gehen und mir
einen job suchen und zwar möchte ich
gerne einen job suchen und zwar möchte
ich gerne wordpress com ich höre gerne
raytracing was mach ich jetzt hier
okay in wie funktioniert es nicht okay
mein job startet angeblich um 8 uhr
morgen eine message will mich daran
erinnern und so weiter und so fort
ich möchte doch nur diese hesse und
jetzt hier mal irgendwie vernünftig
anziehen ich habe aber überhaupt nichts
zum anziehen was ist denn das die fünf
simulator wenn ich immer das ist doch
was ist ein ab 55 tag es gibt es gibt
pfarrer verging kiez alter red carpet
unlock old fashion local clothes okay
das heißt rein theoretisch wenn ich doch
jetzt mal hier und ich gebe da mal ein
fashion und konzern
[Applaus]
das ist genauso wie in gta wenn du auf
einmal im chat findet es am anfang sah
fünf minuten denkst du dir nur so scheiß
auf meinen job alter ich habe gelesen
wenn ich hielt meinen gebe bekomme ich
dauerhaft plus 20.000 alter wo soll ich
denn da noch als watchers arbeiten man
stelle ich mir vor dass wird im real
life gehen so gibt es einen stein hast
alle klamotten die du schon immer wollte
das areal von medizin die ich jetzt mal
hier vor ort gott das ist doch unfassbar
wir können dich doch hübsch machen wie
sonst
ok eventuell sollten wir ein anderes
körperteil zu rwo madoff fucking gott
davon habe ich gesprochen als ich meinte
dass ich mich hübsch mache das ist ich
bin so ein hässliches kleines mädchen
okay ich mache mal party in wald friends
und weite zwei partys habe ich habe zwei
freunde ich glaube dieses spiel ist mein
echtes leben saint martin beils kommen
jetzt hier you started npm altersschnitt
das ist in 14
ich muss ohne den 14 42 14 40 uhr
paradis uhr gar nicht rechnen okay da
hinten fängt die party an das heißt bis
dahin muss ich auf jeden fall irgendwie
fertig muss ein
ich muss alles hat martha fucking
geschlossen wie können ihr wohl die zeit
vorspulen irgendwie so perfekt perfekt
ok go to work nur als ob ich zur arbeit
gehen soll wir gehen jetzt erst mal
beauty care wir gehen das mal beauty
care weil ich will unbedingt einen
besseren herrschen ist sie aus wie
sonnen larry donald da gibt euch mal die
mucke
auch mein gott gibt euch ihre treten
altaras ist los mit der ok ich hole mir
erstmal die ganzen brustimplantate habe
ich mir schon geholt dann hole ich mir
mal eben noch neue lippen also das ist
auch so eigentlich ein ganz normaler
tagesablauf fahrer hin lass mir alles
neu machen an meinem körper was geht und
dann ist alles sogar nach wer möchte
nicht gern so einen körper und solche
hübschen lippen haben
gibbs zufolge ihr seid alle nur neidisch
auf mich auf mich ich das bin ich okay
ich habe alles ausgenutzt was man machen
kann und er möchte mit erinnert mich an
eine youtube
mein gott meine party fängt gleich an
den acht stunden ich muss unbedingt ganz
schnell mit dem bus und abkommen einmal
shoppen geht dort noch einmal stellen
die mall rein das kann nicht sein da
gehe ich mal einmal einkaufen und dann
haben die hier nix mehr als ob einfach
alles ausverkauft ist wollen nämlich
accessoires ich will doch irgendwie nur
was cooles haben aber okay die party
fängt jetzt gleich an das heißt wir
müssen uns mal langsam wieder nach hause
bewegen
das heißt ich geh jetzt hier mit dem bus
schön nach hause schön hier rein und
dann spielen wir vor bis zur party
mein gott freunde mehr passiert einfach
nicht das war's die party ist vorbei 0
fax franz [ __ ] franz was ist das denn
für ein witz so mein gott wie sehe ich
dann aus mal schauen ob ich irgendwann
neues bio wer ist das denn
bis sie denn wenn ich dann das mädel da
ich möchte mal hier oder komme ich erst
mal wirken als ob ich zur arbeit gehe
ich erstmal hier ein paar neue freunde
jetzt hier mal eben schon was frieden
wer ist denn dieses mädchen da hinten ok
dieses spiel besteht daraus dass ich in
meinem zimmer sein kann kann ich mich
nicht einfach denn legen mal also bisher
überzeugt mich dieses spiel vollkommen
und ich finde mich so hübsch das ist und
ich bin dass dieses spiel egal das kann
doch nicht sein die haben immer noch
nichts neues im sortiment was ist denn
das für ein shopping laden wenn einfach
alles out of stock ist ich weiß warum
ich habe er mit dem schon als gekauft
larrys ihr habt nichts mehr anzubieten
dank mir okay als abschließendes zeug
muss ich echt sagen dieses spiel ist
somit ca das langweiligste spiel was ich
je gespielt habe aber es kommt eine neue
party kommen jetzt gehen wir mal vor bis
zur nächsten party mal schauen ob ich da
irgendwelche fakt friends kriege ok
party ist vorbei
habe ich null einem fax das war mein
ziel kann ich meine fakt friends
irgendwie anrufen oder so es ist möglich
kann ich hier nicht ich will auch dieses
spiel nicht mehr spielen diese spiele
scheiße dumm behindert